[Music]
[Music]
i love you
i know
greetings fellow cinephiles i'm ward
garrett and welcome to another episode
of rt essentials this week we are
getting to the heart of the matter to
the spark that steers the plot and makes
the movie world go round
we're talking about love and sometimes
love is all you need to make a great
film
that and a decent budget a solid script
oh believable actors an astute director
producers lighting music
okay fine maybe you need a lot more than
love just make a great film but all
great films do start with the story and
all great stories involve some romance
usually between two characters whether
those characters are already in love or
they'll soon meet and fall head over
heels or they're together and try to
make it work against all odds we can't
help but feel an emotional connection
and commit wholeheartedly to their
journey but with so many movies and so
many couples it's hard to know what to
watch and who to root for fear not my
friends because once again rt essentials
is here to save you from your decision
fatigue so without any further ado these
are the most iconic movie couples
rose and jack titanic no you won't
what do you mean no i won't
don't presume to tell me what i will and
will not do you don't know me
well you would have done it already
you're distracting me go away
i can't i'm involved now
you let go and i'm i'm gonna have to
jump in there after you
starting with rose jewett picarta and
jack dawson more commonly known as rose
and jack of all the couples on this list
and in the history of cinema rose and
jack are arguably the most iconic
partially because 1997's titanic was a
mega hit and became the highest grossing
film of all time
that is until james cameron broke his
own box office record with avatar in
2010. this is also the most expensive
movie ever made at the time and a larger
than life movie requires a
larger-than-life romance enter rose and
jack played by kate winslet and leonardo
dicaprio rose is a 17 year old
philadelphian forced into an unhappy
engagement with an affluent 30 year old
named cal harkley played by billy zane
gosh that's such an american name i love
it rose's mother is determined to
fulfill this arrangement and sees it as
an opportunity for her and rose to
maintain their aristocratic status but
rose just doesn't fancy kale in that way
rightfully so there's an arrogant little
twit as they come
makes for a great antagonist though or
is the glacier technically the
antagonist
speaking of glaciers consider this a
spoiler alert for anyone who's been
living under a rock for the last 110
years the titanic
sinks
back to rose though once aboard the ship
she finds herself so upset by this
loveless engagement that she climbs over
the stern railing and prepares to plunge
into the frigid abyss of the north
atlantic ocean yet cal is that unlikable
anyways it's at this exact moment that
20 year old jack appears and convinces
rose to step back onto the deck their
chemistry is immediate and explosive in
a matter of seconds the two strangers
develop a bond that lasts an eternity
naturally rosa's mother and fiance
disapprove of jack especially since he's
a poor artist who is only able to make
it onto the titanic after winning a
ticket in a poker game but such
disapproval will not stand in the way of
true romance since soon rose and jack
are in the middle of a fully fledged
forbidden love affair leading to some of
the most notorious scenes to ever hit
the big screen these scenes include a
nude sketching paint me like one of your
french women a steamy handprint on a car
and the flying first kiss moment on the
bow
and of course the i'll never let go chat
tragedy at the end
i'll never let go
i promise
[Music]
which caused a lot of controversy there
was plenty of room on the door we all
know that it's called balance life was
in the balance and all he had to do was
figure out the balance we're all mad at
you rose even though you're a fictional
character kate winslet you're okay
carol and charisse carol who strange
girl you are
why
flung out of space
next up we have carol and therese from
the 2015 romantic drama carol directed
by todd haynes and written by phyllis
nagy the screenplay was based on the
1952 novel the price of salt by patricia
highsmith which was republished and
retitled as carol in 1990. the price of
salt was semi-autobiographical with
highsmith basing the character therese
on herself and taking inspiration from
her time working as a sales clerk in the
toy section of bloomingdale's in 1948.
she described one specific interaction
with an elegant blonde woman in a mink
coat who left such an impression on her
that she went home that night and
outlined a book in two hours realising
the next day that she'd been under the
influence of chickenpox that outline
morphed into the story of a forbidden
romance between nineteen-year-old
therese bellave and carol aird an
upperclass wife and mother in her
thirties the price of salt became the
first ever lesbian novel to have a happy
ending and was highsmith's only novel
about an unambiguous lesbian
relationship despite the author being
openly gay
screenwriter phyllis nagy befriended
smith while on assignment for the new
york times back in the late 80s and the
two remained close until highsmith's
passing in 1995. nagi had felt a
responsibility to ensure that the screen
adaptation of carol would stay true to
the source material and spent nearly two
decades trying to get it made several
investors actors and directors came and
went feeling that the script was too
risky because it featured a gay theme
and two female leads ah
well it would be great to catch a ride
yeah sure
you two have a wonderful night
nice meeting you jack nice meeting you
finally todd haynes signed on with kate
blanchet starring as carol and rooney
mara starring as therese blanchette and
mara are electric and audiences were
unanimously moved by their character's
love at first sight romance much like
rose and jack carol and therese come
from different classes and backgrounds
and the prohibited nature of their
affair only proved to ramp up their
desires carroll was ranked by the
british film institute as the best lgbt
film of all time and the bbc named it
one of the greatest films of the 21st
century
harry and sally when harry met sally
meet someone you have the safe lunch you
decide you like each other enough to
move on to dinner you go dancing you do
the white man's overbite
go back to her place you have sex and
the minute you're finished you know what
goes through your mind
how long do i have to lie here and hold
it before i can get up and go home is 30
seconds enough
that's what you're thinking when harry
met sally is a quintessential rom-com
one that seeks to answer the age-old
question of can men and women ever truly
be strictly platonic friends and the
answer is
we still don't really know because harry
and sally can't seem to make up their
minds the film was written by nora
ephron who based harry on an interview
she conducted with director rob reiner
who had recently gone through a divorce
efron based sally on herself and some of
her friends and though the film wasn't
technically autobiographical it was
certainly inspired by real people and
events efron being one of the greats and
pending such superb dialogue is a large
part of what makes this film so
relatable and charming but what meg ryan
and billy crystal bring to the two main
characters is that special kind of magic
the one that morphs a great movie couple
into an iconic one and lands them on
this list crystal is harry burns and
ryan is sally albright two college grads
moving to the big apple to pursue their
respective careers when they're not
arguing they're trying to set each other
up with their friends or questioning the
roles of men and women in relationships
the two are almost the perfect couple
and when they're apart they long for one
another even if they hate the idea of
that there are two kinds of women high
maintenance and low maintenance an
ingrid bergman is low maintenance
and lm definitely which one am i you're
the worst kind you're high maintenance
but you think you're low maintenance
i don't see that it's the epitome of
can't live with them can't live without
him we've all had someone like that in
our lives which is why audiences connect
to harry and sally on such a deep level
stylistically rhino shot the film like a
true love letter to new york city using
staples of the city as backdrops and
locations like that one scene at the
infamous cat's delicatessen you know the
whole i'll have which is having seen
it's still one of the most widely
recognized moments in cinema history
when harry met sally was unanimously
praised by critics and audiences across
the globe roger ebert summed it up
perfectly writing that what makes this
film special apart from the efron
screenplay is the chemistry between
crystal and ryan
ennis and jack broke back mountain i
wish i knew how to quit you
why don't you
why don't you just let me be huh
adapted from a 1997 short story
brokeback mountain is a romance drama
directed by ang lee and written by larry
mcmurty and diana asana it's the tale of
a rodeo cowboy named jack twist played
by jake gyllenhaal and ranch hand named
ennis del mar played by the late heath
ledger the two men are hired as sheep
herders in wyoming and one night as
they're camping on brokeback mountain
jack makes a drunken pass on ennis who
reciprocates and the two men develop a
love affair that lasts two decades ennis
ends up marrying his longtime sweetheart
alma and jack marries a fellow rodeo
rider named laureen but the two men
maintain their relationship while
attempting to hide its true nature even
in the beginning ennis was far more
reluctant to show affection than jack
and there's good reason for that when
ennis was a young boy his father made it
clear that being gay was not an option
and even showed him the body of a man
who was tortured and killed for
suspected homosexuality but jack was
quicker to embrace his true feelings and
often spoke of creating an honest future
with ennis living on a ranch in peace
unfortunately the two never make it
there
he used to say he wanted his ashes
scattered on brokeback mountain but
i wasn't sure where that was i broke
back mountain might be around where he
grew up
knowing jack it might be some pretend
place
where a blue bird sing and there's a
whiskey spring
it is a heartbreaking film filled with
pain and longing and the torture of
having to cloak one's true identity in
spite of that though eners and jack make
a beautiful couple shooting star soul
mates that were destined to collide
though the world wouldn't accept such a
fate quincy and monica love and
basketball i'll play you
what one game one-on-one
for what
your heart
gina prince bathwood wrote and directed
love and basketball the cult classic
sports drama about
love and basketball but more
specifically about two childhood friends
who aspire to be professional basketball
players this leads us to the next iconic
movie couple on our list quincy and
monica played by omar epps and sanaa
lathan quincy is a natural and
basketball runs in his family his father
zeke is already a pro playing for the
los angeles clippers monica's path isn't
so clear-cut as a girl she has to work
extra hard to establish herself despite
their differences quincy and monica
immediately bond over their shared love
of the sport and as they blossom into
young adults their passion for the game
and for each other only grows
that is until some drama unfolds at
college and the couple breaks up you
forgot to be there
that night you wanted to talk about your
dad i had curfew what was i supposed to
do stay if i stayed i wouldn't be
starting at least you got your
priorities straight
i never asked you to choose you never
have to
i'm a ball player
if anybody knows what that means it
should be you quincy ends up playing for
the la lakers and monica is now playing
for the international women's basketball
association team in barcelona they're
living out their childhood dreams and
they should be happy something's off
though when quincy gets injured during a
game monica flies home to see him the
quincy is now engaged to another woman
once quincy heals monica challenges him
to a high-stakes game of one-on-one if
she wins quincy must call off his
wedding he accepts the challenge and
wins but he knows deep down that monika
is his person so he cancels his wedding
anyway dude as soon as you accepted that
match you already knew
in the end monica and quincy end up
together with monica playing for the
newly established wnba and quincy and
their daughter cheering her on
princess leia and han solo star wars
saga stuck up half-witted
scruffy-looking nerf herder this next
couple needs no introduction i'm of
course talking about princess leia and
han solo from the star wars saga yes
even an epic space opera with death
stars and lightsaber fights wookies
ewoks and a small green jedi who speaks
in an astrophy still has a love story at
its core let's just
make sure to fast forward through the
part where luke falls in love with leia
his own sister and they oh they smooch
oh it's awkward okay cool now that we're
past that let's continue from the moment
han and leia first meet in star wars a
new hope you can feel the tension
building yes han believes that leia is a
spoiled princess and leia views han as a
slimy selfish smuggler who doesn't seem
to take no for an answer but we can see
right through those incessant insults we
just know that these two are destined to
end up together george lucas being a
master of story and suspense makes us
wait until empire strikes back for the
two to finally share their first kiss
but wow
it was worth that delay because this
kiss aboard han's ship the millennium
falcon is one of the most beautifully
acted and perfectly scored moments in
cinema history and it symbolizes a
turning point in han and leia's
relationship
stop that
stop what
stop that my hands are dirty my hands
are dirty too what are you afraid of
afraid
you're trembling
[Music]
[Music]
together the two helped save the galaxy
from the evil shit's lord palpatine city
yes and his imperial fleet and
eventually give birth to a son named ben
solo
unfortunately though ben is seduced by
the dark side changes his name to kylo
ren throws a lot of tantrums has a lot
of his own problems and then he kills
his father but that's beside the point
like all of the movie couples on this
list it's the real life actors that make
them shine so shout out to harrison ford
and the late and great carrie fisher for
creating two of the most legendary
characters to ever hit the silver screen
may the force be with you
mark and bridget bridget jones franchise
perhaps despite appearances
i like you
very much
huh apart from the smoking and the
drinking and the vulgar mother
and the verbal doctor i like you very
much
just as you are the bridget jones
franchise is based on helen fielding's
novels of the same name and the first of
the three films was released in 2001.
these movies were wildly popular
collectively grossing over 756
million dollars and earning numerous
accolades but so much of that popularity
can be attributed to the enthralling
relationship between this next couple on
our list mark darcy and bridget jones
played by colin firth and renee
zellweger bridget is how dare she 32 and
working at a publishing company in
london where she obsesses over her
weight and fantasizes about her boss
daniel
mark is an upper-class barrister not to
be confused with a barista who makes
fancy latte art he is introduced to
bridget at her parents new year party
though they grew up in the same
neighborhood and were childhood
acquaintances much like han and leia the
two immediately butt heads mark finds
bridget to be foolish and vulgar and
bridget thinks that mark is arrogant and
rude but if star wars taught us anything
these are the makings of a loving
relationship soon feelings start to
develop but not before mark gets into a
fist fight in the streets with his
friend and bridget's boss pseudo
boyfriend daniel this causes bridget to
reject both men and mark to eventually
accept a job in new york with his new
soon-to-be fiance but like any good
rom-com things always get rocky before
they pan out and all of these events
culminate in one of the most romantic
scenes of all time in which a pantsless
bridget chases after mark and the two
kiss in the snow-covered street
it's only a diary
everyone knows diaries are just
full of crap
i know that
i'm just buying you a new one
time to make a new start perhaps
[Music]
it's worth noting that all sorts of baby
drama unfold over the next two films but
the snow kiss seemed like a great place
to wrap things up
kevin and chiron moonlight you always
let them pick on you
so
what i gotta do
all you gotta do
show these you ain't soft
but i ain't so
i know i know
but it don't mean nothing if they don't
know
come on
you want these fools to pick on you
every day
see
i know you wasn't saw moonlight was the
first lgbtq film to take home the oscar
for best picture and supporting actor
mahershala ali became the first muslim
to ever win an oscar this film was
groundbreaking and defiant on so many
levels and centered around a love story
between one couple chiron and kevin the
movie is presented as three defining
chapters in chiron's life childhood
played by alex hibbert teenage years
played by ashton sanders and adulthood
played by travanti rhodes chiron is born
to a crack addicted mother in a
tumultuous miami neighborhood where he's
humiliated for being gay at an early age
and chooses to keep it a secret chiron
and kevin are childhood friends and
share the pains of having to hide their
true identities in a rough neighborhood
they grow closer and one night on a
beach kevin and tyrone kiss and become
intimate for the next day at school
kevin is tricked into hazing and beating
up chiron and fears the repercussions of
not giving in to the peer pressure
brought on by the other bullies it's a
difficult scene to watch but a harrowing
glimpse into how dangerous it is for
kevin and chiron to be open about their
sexuality now as adults chiron travels
back to miami and visits kevin at his
workplace though kevin is now a father
he still thinks of chiron and wonders
what might have been i just
just thought about you and i
we got this jukebox in here and um
folks come by and play these songs
that's the music we're getting here in
this it's dude man
so
i mean if you ever come to town man you
come out
i'll cook you some
[Music]
maybe
maybe play that song for you all right
man um it'd be easy all right
though their romance never fully came to
fruition their love for each other
didn't falter
jamal and latika slumdog millionaire
lover
[Laughter]
[Music]
2008 slumdog millionaire was one of the
most revered movies of the year and took
home an impressive eight out of ten
oscar nominations it's the story of 18
year old jamal malik played by dev patel
whose troublesome life on the streets of
mumbai equips him with an expansive
array of knowledge when jamal lands
himself on india's version of who wants
to be a millionaire he uses this
knowledge and experience to correctly
answer questions and ultimately win the
grand prize but demar's true motivation
for going on the show is to win the
heart of his one true love latica who he
spent years of his life searching for
the two met as young orphans in the
slums but a series of unfortunate events
ripped them apart and latika ends up
living under the abusive control of a
gangster named jarvad
where are you
i'm safe
10 seconds
uh latika what do you think
i don't know
i've never known
[Music]
jamal's brother saleem eventually helps
latika escape and jamal and latika
reunite at a train station and share one
long-awaited kiss and dance the journey
that leads to this moment is tragic
gut-wrenching but well worth to see
these two lovebirds together at last dev
patel and frida pinto received critical
praise for their performances and rose
to prominence as a result of the film's
success
noah and ali the notebook go i lost you
once i think i could do it again if i
thought it's what you really wanted
but don't you take the easy way out what
easy way there is no easy way no matter
what i do somebody gets hurt would you
stop thinking about what everyone wants
stop thinking about what i want what he
wants what your parents want
what do you want and last up we have the
relationship that made me feel like i
could never truly love again it is noah
and ally from 2004's the notebook
directed by nick cassavetes and based on
the nicholas sparks novel of the same
name the movie is way better than the
book trust me on that ryan gosling plays
noah a mill worker in south carolina who
falls desperately in love with a rich
girl named ally played by rachel mcadams
ali is in town with her parents for the
summer and though she's crazy about noah
her parents don't approve and forbid
them from seeing each other ali and her
family return to charleston and noah
writes ally a letter every single day
for a year i wrote you every day for a
year unaware that ali's mother is
intercepting these letters feeling
deflated noah stops writing to ali and
enlists to fight in world war ii during
this period ali meets a young lawyer and
the two become engaged which her parents
are thrilled about when noah returns
from the war he discovers that his
father has sold their house so that noah
can buy and restore the windsor
plantation which is what he promised
he'd eventually do for ally years
earlier during their summer romance
and you really did it
what
everything
house
it's beautiful what you did
well i promised you i would
convinced that building this house will
be enough to bring ali back noah
completes the job turns out he was
actually right because when ali learns
of this she returns to seabrook and
finds noah living in their dream house
actually first she faints but then she
runs to find noah and the two live
happily ever after once the details with
ali's impending marriage and all that
other fun stuff gets resolved and there
you have it our picks for the most
iconic movie couples as always we
couldn't mention every notable couple to
ever hit the big screen that would just
take way too much time and make me
depressed but don't fret we've got
plenty of arty essential episodes coming
right at you so i'm sure we'll get there
eventually thanks again for tuning in
i'm lord garrett and always remember
movie romances end for all kinds of
reasons but when all is said and done
they have one thing in common they are
shooting stars a spectacular moment of
light in the heavens a fleeting glimpse
of eternity and then in a flash
they're gone
never forget that
[Music]
[Music]
you